[Music]
delivering a successful team
presentation is just like any team
activity the key question is how can we
deliver something collectively at a
level that is as high if not higher than
what we could deliver as individuals
let's start by talking about two teams
first Team USA's men's Olympic relay
team this is a team consisting of some
of the most elite athletes in the world
some of the world's fastest men and add
to that of the 21 times that this event
took place before 2008 the US had won 15
gold medals does anyone know how many
medals they've won since 2008 it's only
happened three times probably zero they
haven't won since 2008 in 2008 they were
disqualified for dropping a baton in
2012 they were disqualified for
off-the-field reasons and in 2016 in Rio
they were disqualified for handing over
the baton outside of the designated zone
this team of elite international
superstars didn't win the medals that
should have been theirs for the taking
because they couldn't perfect the team
elements of their event now let's talk
about the Japanese men's Olympic relay
team also a team consisting of fast
runners of course there are a few
differences prior to 2008 Japan had 1-0
medals in this event and in the last 12
years not a single one of their runners
has ever run 100 meters in less than 10
seconds in fact this is the lineup that
competed in the final in Rio these be
the eight countries and these are the
sums of the individual personal bests of
the four runners in each team so
remember this is a sprinting race you
want the shortest on you want the
smallest bar you can see that Japan or
about 1.3 seconds slower than the US now
you might think 1.3 seconds that's not
really a big deal but in the field of
Olympic sprinting if you're 1.3 seconds
behind someone it might as well be your
grandmother running
race Japan however unknown for
meticulously preparing and practicing
their transitions down to exactly where
they grip the baton exactly when between
slides they exchange the baton and
exactly which runners should pass it to
each other
given the complementary nature of their
running styles and guess what
Japan shocked the world in both 2008 and
2016 winning silver medals and having
the respect of the best for the quality
of their transitions they mastered the
team elements of their event and
collectively they were better than the
sum of their parts
now those critical team moments aren't
so different in the context of a team
presentation you still have to think
about how can we practice and prepare
how should we line up who should speak
when and what should they say how can we
go as smoothly as possible from one
speaker to the next speaker and how can
we organize ourselves to handle couples
or field questions let's look at the
first of those the practice the best
thing you can do in preparation for a
team presentation is to recreate the
actual environment in which you'll end
up presenting that means to whatever
extent possible prepare as a team so
you're aware of not only what you're
doing but what the person before you and
the person after is doing as well
actually walk through the motions of
your transitions if you practice with
person a in one place person being
another and try and squash them together
on the day I can assure you it won't
work very well if you can visit the
venue where you'll be presenting think
about where you'll stand when you're the
speaker where you'll stand when you're
waiting to speak and how you'll move
from one position to another and finally
be sure to practice with the technology
think about who's going to bring it on
the day who will hold it
how will you pass it between yourselves
and finally for bonus points if you
really want to know the smoothness of
your transition you can try what they
call in the theater world a cue to cue
rehearsal this is where you run through
every individual piece of the
presentation saying only your first and
last lines again and again so you're
super aware of exactly how the person
after you starts their piece and exactly
how the person before you ends their
piece these are all tiny things which
when they go well you won't notice but
when they go wrong they can blow up your
presentation before you can practice
it's important to know what role
everyone has on your team the best place
to start is knowing everyone's strengths
in track in the track relay this means
who are your fastest sprinters and the
positions you want to put them in are
the lead and the anchor the leads role
is to get you started off on the right
foot and try to gain that edge in the
beginning of race where as the anchors
job is to cover up any lost ground lost
along the way and help take that team
across the finish line this bookend
strategy works the same with team
presentations you want your strongest
speakers to go first and last to help
set the stage for your talk and help
recap it at the end the other reason you
want to do this is something that we
learned in OB which is the serial
position effect where you're much more
likely to remember the first thing you
heard and the last in a series and kind
of forget the things in the middle which
is great news for me does it entirely
matter what I say cuz you're probably
going to forget it
the last thing you want to do is to all
your experts in the filling or in the
middle of your presentation we like just
like in track relay if you're really
good at passing off the baton or
catching the baton you don't want those
people to go first and last because they
had that critical expertise we also see
this in technical presentations for
example our beloved Steve Jobs keynote
for Steve Jobs will give a general intro
he will then invite experts to the stage
to give their technical demo and then at
the end Steve Jobs would give a general
conclusion to the event so when
assigning roles make sure you know who
your generalists are your experts are
and then bookend them or sandwich them
accordingly and once you do that it's
time to figure out how you're gonna move
from one person to the next
switching between speakers it's in this
nature very distracting to the audience
however group transitions can help
transitions can serve as signposts to
navigate your audience from one topic to
the other when the four thoughts came
together to prepare for this
presentation
we did the following we came up with a
structure with design designated roles
and then parts to different people then
we decided to focus on transitions
however it's not like perfect right
however what we found out is that it was
extremely challenging to come up with
screw transitions because even though we
knew the topic of each other's section
but do not know what they are gonna talk
about transitions are difficult because
you're required to not only have a
matter e of your own content but also
have a deep understanding of what your
teammates are gonna talk about therefore
it's a simple indicator for how well the
team works together and a bad transition
can simply give away that even though
each of you is great you don't work well
as a team so let's look at some examples
you might have seen transitions where
there's just no transitions
or you met have also seen the fall cost
is an important factor in our decision
now Casey will tell us all about how
revenue is also a big factor in our
decision hi I'm Casey revenue it's also
an important factor in decision so that
was just a mere repetition of what was
just said it's not very effective is it
is that case you could have set the
following cost is one of many important
factors now let's move to revenue thank
you so that way she came on the stage
summarizes and then transitions
alternatively you can also post a
question that your next speaker answers
now we have a cup of tea tips on how to
come up transitions verbally how do you
actually make the transition making good
use of the space without making a mess
so keep in mind someone should always be
in charge of the physical space meaning
that you should never leave the stage
empty secondly don't speak while you are
not yet the focus of the stage you can
just be walk to the place get ready so
that your audience ready and then you
can start speaking that's way more
effective than just speaking while
you're walking so it covered how to
prepare for a team presentation how to
transition from one another but how can
we efficiently fill questions as a team
so I imagine many of you have seen a
group presentation that goes something
like this it's nearing the end of the
presentation and everything is going
smoothly
you've hit all of your talking points
and you're moving from person to person
with ease that is until you hit the Q&A
the audience poses the first question
and it's a bit more challenging than the
group had anticipated so everyone is
silent
in that uncomfortable pause one of the
team members steps up but it's not their
area of expertise and they offer an
opinion that contradicts something that
was previously said in the presentation
the next question comes in and multiple
people jump in trying to avoid what had
previously occurred the effect of this
is that it undermines the overall
quality of the presentation and often
leaves the audience confused about how
to process the information given did see
this is like having a relay team without
a captain there's no one there to help
coordinate the athletes and help them
shine as they cross the finish line so
what can you actually do about this
first start by designating a coach or
coordinator this person is responsible
for opening the audience to QA selecting
the participants to make sure that only
one person is being called on at a time
and then helping the team to understand
who is going to tackle that question you
can think of them kind of like a
moderator on a panel next before the
presentation actually starts you want to
coordinate across your group to
understand who has specific areas of
expertise and what questions they're
going to be teed up to answer oftentimes
this comes naturally and aligns with the
content of the presentation that had
previously been given but you'll want to
make sure that everyone's on the same
page ahead of time so with that we'd
actually like to open it up to the Q&A
portion of our conversation what
questions can we help answer about
mastering a group presentation
[Music]